he emerged in a pool of light and after
a dark night of uncertainty Donald Trump
chose to draw a line under an escalating
feud that could color relations in the
region for years to come
I'm pleased to inform you the American
people should be extremely grateful and
happy no Americans were harmed in last
night's attack by the Iranian regime
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world a fighter by nature he avoided
ramping up the rhetoric of war calling
for progress and launching a challenge
to his European partners instead the
time has come for the United Kingdom
Germany France Russia and China to
recognize this reality they must now
break away from the remnants of the Iran
deal so for today at least America's
commander-in-chief opted not to beat the
drum of war flying in the face if those
who feared more retribution until now
this administration has been scrambling
to explain its Middle East strategy just
as the president's team has been talking
about de-escalation he has been talking
about the many ways in which he could
devastate Iran if Americans are
threatened but he sees his
unpredictability as a strength he revels
in the idea he can take his enemies by
surprise and he has certainly done that
in taking out the second most important
figure in Iran on Capitol Hill his
Republican allies applauded his
decisiveness so he said what do you
think there's tit for tat has ultimately
achieved tit for tat won't achieve
anything their strategic goals were laid
out today what's missing I thought after
killing sulemani is what is this all
about
well this is about ending 40 years of
destructive behavior and not having 40
more are you reassured by the
president's tone he appeared to take
this off the ramp and talk about
reconciliation and progress in Iraq
I think it's as close to the possibility
of seeking a different path with Iran
than the president will get in his words
god bless america
thank you very much thank you Democrats
may question the legality of the strike
but for now Iran has been able to send a
symbolic warning shot and mr. Trump has
fired his own with a boldness his
predecessors resisted cordelia Lynch Sky
News Washington